okay let's go back to the phones at 6 1
7 8 3 0 47 50 let's check in with oh you
know who's on the phone
Ulysses is on the phone who is a docker
recipient and it's been almost six
months since we heard from Ulysses hey
ulysses how are you hello I'm good
good what's new uh you know I just had a
renewal underway you did okay good
that's fantastic
yeah he's got a question for you okay
but you don't sound that happy about the
docker renewal no no I am happy I'm just
tired of this in the morning I got some
yes as we got a question for you sure I
did wonder I mean what's like the the
main root of anti-semitism do you think
does it have to do with the killing of
Jesus Christ or do you think it's
something else
I don't think no listen Jews have been
convenient scapegoats for a really long
time and there's been a feedback loop
where the ways in which Jews were
discriminated against perpetuated
circumstances that led to further
discrimination so like let me give you
an example you have all of these
conspiracy theories now about Jews
conspiring to control certain industries
so on and so forth that is something
that has come from prior discrimination
against Jews where they were not allowed
to participate in society in a whole
bunch of different areas which push them
into fields that require or at benefit
from sitting around reading and
discussing and thinking about stuff so
it's it's been this very unfortunate
circle where Jews have been scapegoated
for something and then there's
scapegoating and discrimination against
them furthers the feedback loop such
that there are new things for which they
are scapegoated and discriminated
against and I I don't think you know the
the entire killing Jesus thing seems to
look like a cartoonish sort of not
really practical
reason for modern anti-semitism wasn't
the Romans that killed Jesus to the
extent that Jesus existed I don't even
know I mean yeah but I don't know too
much about the killing I mean I don't
know it's just I think that's just like
Bible scholars I'd be hearing behind
that stuff and I gotcha
yeah and do you what do you do you also
think that Islamic terrorists also hate
Jews because many of them are
anti-semitic yes yes absolutely you know
why why are you doing because I'm not
understanding that yeah but extremist
Islam is not particularly fond of the
Jews that's for sure yeah all right you
listening thank you I really am glad
that you got your doc extension though I
really that that's a great thing
yeah thank you all right Ulysses we'll
talk to you soon take care